uh to reset here the main secretary of
state is now decided to Bar Donald Trump
from appearing on the ballot in the
state of Maine joining what Colorado is
doing well to give us further analysis
we're going to bring in Jonathan Turley
George Washington University law
professor and just a real expert in this
uh Jonathan Turley what's your take on
what's Happening Here in
Maine well some of us had stated earlier
that we thought Maine would go the way
of Colorado I said that just today in a
column of why these Challengers went to
Maine Bellow wrote right after uh
January 6 that it was an Insurrection
and kept on with those uh criticisms for
uh um the whole period after that so she
was on the record as saying that Donald
Trump in fact did engage in an
Insurrection so this was one of those
challenges where the aners seem clear
you've got to keep in mind this is the
secretary of state of Maine this is not
a court and many of these challenges in
States like Colorado were brought by
Democratic or approved by Democratic
secretaries of State they then have to
face judicial scrutiny I am hoping that
the court system in Maine has the same
Integrity as many other states and
rejects this Theory uh it is really
striking how Bellow cloaks herself as a
defender of democracy in this statement
when she's preventing voters from
casting their vote for what is currently
the leading candidate for the presidency
so it's it's a very odd claim to make in
my view but the theory here I in many of
the our view many of us view it as being
being fundamentally flawed you know the
14th Amendment section three deals with
Insurrection or Rebellion many of us do
not believe it was either in fact
polling shows that the public views it
as a protest that became a riot I think
that is accurate I but there are a host
of problems in applying this provision
to Donald Trump so the question now is
is will this add to the urgency for the
Supreme Court to rule I hope hope it
does I hope that it can deal with this
matter with finality and hopefully
unanimity and to put this dangerous
Theory a way for
good yeah how they actually go out and
make this claim repeatedly for somebody
who's never been charged with this and
never convicted of something that is a
serious crime in this country is truly
stunning to me Jonathan Turley we
appreciate you dropping everything in
your night during this holiday week and
joining us for analysis we really do
truly appreciate it thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else